[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qui vous amène ici ce soir quand notre
consultant qu'est-ce que cela signifie que le
voleur de banque accompli est vraiment nul
qui a demandé pourquoi il a apporté des sacs
remarque soudaine parce que c'est là que se trouve l'argent
[Musique]
si certains étaient vivants aujourd'hui ne
voleraient pas des banques  il volerait les
riches c'est un bingo très important
je ne vais pas faire ça pour toujours je
pense que j'en ai deux de plus que j'en ai fini alors
je sors c'est adorable
ton père était en moi pendant un bon bout de temps
il me semble  comme peut-être que vous
essayez de nettoyer quand la femme d'un père
pense que ça va dans l'autre sens je
voulais de quoi tu parles
allez tu pourrais utiliser mon aide je suis Mark Reeth
je suis Karen Elise vous les enfants avez un grand
temps
[Musique]
vous êtes un couple si mignon
merci pourquoi me suivez-vous FBI au cours des
trois dernières années vous et vos copains avez
décroché plus de 75 millions de dollars au
marché noir que voulez-vous de moi
l'homme avec le  planifier celui-ci est grand encore
un petit travail et vous et moi avons
fini quoi  sont les options mes options sont
mourir ou ne pas mourir d'accord tu ne me dis
pas que tu ne dérapes pas ce n'est peut-être pas toi
ça peut être une petite amie instable ou
un frère bipolaire il y a toujours une fissure
que diriez-vous d'un moment de silence combien de
plus  moments Johanna fais-
tu
toi